in washington the house has passed a  bill to solidify lgbtq protections  it's called the equality act it amends  existing civil rights laws to include  sexual orientation and  gender identity as protected  characteristics  that rule would apply to things like  employment housing and education  the protections are a top priority for  the biden administration and house  speaker nancy pelosi  and it is sadly necessary i wish that it  weren't  sometimes i just wonder why it is but it  is sadly necessary  because many members of the national  lgbtq community  live in states where though they have  the right to marry  they have no state level  non-discrimination protections  in other areas of life the bill now  moves to the senate  lawmakers say it's likely to have a  tough time getting through there